sous une robe sûr sensation
bonjour et bienvenue dans un europe sur
radio sensations en association avec tv
78 une émission enregistrée au parlement
européen de strasbourg voici le sommaire
de cette nouvelle émission la
chancelière allemande angela merkel va
quitter ses fonctions après 16 ans au
pouvoir je recevrai l'eurodéputé
allemand jan christoph hudson
l'anniversaire de la chute du mur de
berlin dans la nuit du 9 novembre 1989
quels souvenirs en gardez-vous c'est la
question que nous avons posée voyager
dans l'assiette ni classes rime chef du
kit ce bistrot allemand à paris nous
donnera la recette des roulades les
superstitions en europe evelyne keller
auteur du livre 300 une superstition
petite encyclopédie des peurs échelle et
sagesse populaire la couleur verte
porte-t-elle malheur c'est ce que nous
verrons à la fin de cette émission mais
avant que fait l'europe dans notre
région un exemple tout dessus
saône robe l'europe dans ma région
aujourd'hui je suis avec visite commune
environ une heure de paris on est plus
précisément au panier de la ferme c'est
une boutique qui travaille
essentiellement avec des producteurs
locaux et la petite particularité c'est
qu'elle a bénéficié à plusieurs reprises
d'être européenne pour plusieurs projets
on a rendez vous avec philippe geron
pour en parler
[Musique]
oui je m'appelle philippe moi je suis
agriculteur donc je suis quelqu'un je
suis plutôt agriculteurs en grandes
cultures
et je me suis diversifiée
en regroupant la production locale alors
la carte c'est nos producteurs donc vous
voyez tout sur la carte principale donc
c'est tous les producteurs qui sont à
moins de 30 km de la ferme donc c'est le
principalement tous nos producteurs dans
un premier temps puis je voulais mettre
en place des paniers de produits locaux
qui distribuait aux clients ce projet a
justement été financé à 50% par les
fonds européens l'europe m'a aidé à
constituer tout ce qui était site
internet grosso modo j'ai investi dix
mille euros au départ et et j'ai touché
50 % de subventions
tourner la boutique est juste en dessous
et c'est cette voiture là qui étaient
fortement abîmée et du coup on a mis des
panneaux photovoltaïques donc
l'investissement s'élève à peu près à
160000 euros
et j'ai touché 25 % de subventions la
moitié par l'europe et la moitié par la
région ile de france le corps de ferme
est quand même assez grand et demande
beaucoup de frais là on m'a proposé dans
une grange qui commençait à être à
l'abandon et qui se défraîchir s'est
fortement de faire des logements
étudiants donc je vous dis amen allons-y
donc là on est devant l'ancienne grange
qui était à l'abandon qui est devenue
maintenant
des logements étudiants les jeunes qui
sont là ce sont des étudiants ou des
premiers emplois on va dire fait que des
meublés et les loyers sont environ 25%
inférieurs aux loyers que l'on trouve
dans le secteur en équivalent avec cette
troisième est d'européennes philippe a
donc pu mettre en place ces six
logements étudiants le coût total de ce
projet s'élevait à 367 1000 euros dont
28% a été financé par des fonds
européens
[Musique]
sous drop
le 3 octobre dernier c'était le jour de
la fête nationale en allemagne le 3
octobre 1990 l'ex rda et rfa fusionné
pour former plus qu'une seule nation la
chute du mur de berlin le 9 novembre
1989 a été le point de départ de ce
processus de réunification
quel souvenir en gardez vous c'est la
question que nous vous avons posé la
liberté qui allait être trouvée et la
réunion de deux peuples allemand qui en
fait chacun
écoutez je me trouvais à paris c'était
vraiment une journée une grande journée
de liesse à bas j'étais pas bien je
j'avais 7 ans et je me rappelle très
bien que mon père regarder les infos et
qu'il est en train de courir après ma
soeur et qui m'a attrapé sur le jeu en
misant oriente là il faut que tu
regardes et tu avais pas ce qui se passe
quelque chose d'important le monde en
train de changer donc voilà c'est ça que
ça me va comme souvenir on va écouter
effectivement c'était
un jour particulier je me souviens avoir
vu
n'avoir vu à la télévision avec
avec tous les jeunes qui cassent et le
mur et c'était quelque chose
d'impressionnant c'est toute une époque
qui se tourner je me rappelle ma
jeunesse dans 89 et ça me rappelle qu'à
l'époque tout était permis et je me
rappelle que c'était pour moi la commune
délivrance une porte qui s'ouvrait déjà
début années 80 il y avait le monde
socialiste qui arrivait c'était plus
d'ouverture de radios libres et puis de
l'autre côté en 89 j'étais un petit peu
la fin de le de la halle empire
soviétique
c'était un petit peu à un monde qui
s'écroule et un autre qui repartaient
c'était un passage entre deux mondes ça
me rappelle la naissance de ma fille
parce que ça ait lieu en mars 1989 et
puis la formidable liesse des personnes
qui est à l'est qui pouvait retrouver
certains de leurs des membres de leur
famille et puis ce mur qui séparait de
un pays en deux c'était
c'était moche et il le fait qu'ils aient
été détruits c'est c'était superbe il y
avait une liesse en plus générale sur
sur le monde entier et c'était une
barrière qui tombe est et c'était très
très beaux
zoos d'europe ce jour là
ce jour là le 22 novembre 2005 angela
merkel devenait la chancelière
d'allemagne désigner un an plus tard la
femme la plus puissante du monde en gala
merkel s'est rapidement hissé au rang de
leader en europe les dates clés de son
parcours avec europe direct et la maison
de l'europe le 22 novembre 2005 angela
merkel devient la plus jeune et la
première femme élue chancelière elle
sera réélue en 2009 en 2013 et pour un
quatrième mandat en 2018 après six mois
d'impasse politique
le 1er septembre 2006 en gala merkel
détrône la secrétaire d'état américaine
condoleezza rice et prend la tête du
classement des femmes les plus
puissantes du monde publié par le
magazine forbes le 30 mai 2011 angela
merkel décide de sortir du nucléaire une